si él es presidente de donald tram y sus
dos hijos mayores tendrán que prestar
declaración bajo juramento en el marco
de la investigación por fraude que está
llevando a cabo la fiscal general del
estado de nueva york letitia james así
lo acaba de anunciar hace poco menos de
dos horas un juez de la corte suprema ha
dicho que ivanka trump a donald júnior
trump y el expresidente donald trump
tendrán que contestar preguntas acerca
de sus negocios comerciales justo en un
día en el que se estaba celebrando un
encuentro contencioso porque los trama
habían pedido que se anularán las
citaciones que pedía la fiscal general
del estado de nueva york bien no va a
ser así ya lo ha dicho un juez los tres
van a tener que declarar porque según la
fiscal general del estado de nueva york
y cito textualmente se han encontrado
valores fraudulentos el uso de valores
fraudulentos y engañosos de su
patrimonio de los trump para obtener
préstamos y beneficios fiscales así que
ahora deberá declarar bajo juramento
sobre estos negocios el juez también ha
dicho que ahora los trans tienen 21 días
para esta declaración posiblemente y
recurran este fallo para no tener que
declarar pero en caso de que siguiera
adelante los traten en dos opciones
contestar las preguntas o bien
mantenerse en silencio acogiéndose a la
quinta enmienda que básicamente les
permite no autoincriminarse